so my name is gajendra dande and today
I'm going to deliver a talk on fighting
moneya laundering with python and open
source
software so in today's talk we are going
to discuss uh these topics in brief so
first one is forensic investigation
process then double standard and the
python then bank account analysis or
fund Trail analysis so that's the main
Crux of anti-money laundering then how
are we going to do it so there are
basically three concepts here one is
benfor law then second one is
visualization then third one is logging
and finally I'm going to conclude my
talk sorry gendra you're currently on
the uh PowerPoint slide and not the
shared screen slide I believe okay just
a minute so now is now is it
okay yeah yeah looking good now thanks
yeah thank you so uh let's start the
discussion with forensic investigation
process so there are are basically six
steps first one is identification then
second one is collection third one is
validation fourth one is examination
fifth one is Preservation and finally
presentation so what happens in
identification step is that
investigative officers visit the crime
location crime scene and they are going
to collect all the objects of
suspects now in case of anti-money
laundering they are going to identify
the suspects and approach the banks and
collect their Bank
statements this is very very important
and in usual forensic investigation
process they will also take into
consideration Tak to their custody uh
different devices different electronic
devices including pen drives toy pend
drives hard disk computer mobile Etc and
one of the important aspect to note here
is that they have to preserve the state
of the machine that is if the system is
on they should not turn it off if the
system is off they should not turn turn
it on because there can be evidence that
can be present in the volatile memory
and there is the order in which they
have to collect the evidence and the
order is they have to collect the
evidence from most volatile memory first
and least volatile memory
last then once they identify the
different objects the next step is
collection and when they're collecting
they have to store all this information
all these devices in special plastic
bags they're also called as
electrostatic bags or Faraday bags and
they have to make sure that the evidence
is not
tampered then after this they have to
perform
validation so generally what happens is
that they also take the snapshot of the
system and in our case they are going to
work with the soft copy of the bank
statements and it may happen that
whenever we are performing some analysis
some softwares May alter the information
and if it adds the information then it
may create a problem in the code so they
have to make sure that the software
doesn't interfere with the evidence so
that's why they always work on the copy
of the data so we're going to see how
are we going to validate the information
whether the information is altered or no
later with python C example so right now
I can say that you can make use of
hashing algorithms for that to preserve
the Integrity of the
information then fourth step is
examination so here what happens is that
we usually get evidence in different
pieces okay and in examination step we
are going to process the evidence we are
going to analyze the evidence
and find the correlation between
different pieces of
evidence so that is very very important
here the next is
Preservation so all the evidence all the
objects whatever are collected by the
investigation officers they need to be
stored at proper location properly in
the safe at appropriate temperature
right so with
proper passwords encryption mechanisms
and so on they have to make sure that
the information is not tempered nobody
is accessing the information then final
step is very very important important
that is
presentation so there is a particular
format in which all these steps have to
be carried out and it needs to be
presented in the court of law if you
don't follow the procedure led by the
investigation
agencies then your evidence may not be
accepted in the court so that's why you
have to follow the steps specified by
law enforcement agencies here that is
very very
important
okay so next we are going to see is the
double standard and
python so basically in United States
federal law there is something called as
Dober standard it's also called as the
rule of evidence and it's regarding the
admissibility of expert witness
testimony so here a party May raise a
dber motion a special Motion in lemon
raised before or during trial so to
exclude the presentation unqualified
evidence to the jury so this is very
very important here okay then there are
some illustrative factors set by the
court and Court says that these all come
under scientific
methodology as the process of
formulating hypothesis and then
conducting experiments to prove or
falsify the
hypothesis and these are provided by
some set of illustrative
factors and Supreme Court suggested the
following factors so first is has the
technique been tested in the actual
field conditions and not just in
laboratory has the technique been
subject to peer review and
publication what is the known or
potential rate of
error then do standards exist for
control of techniqus operation and last
one is has the technique been generally
accepted within the relevant scientific
community so in this slide we'll see how
the illustrative factors mentioned in
the previous slide are related to python
or how they can be mapped one to one
with Python programming language so in
2003 Brian carrier published a paper
that examined Rules of Evidence
standards including Dober and he
compared and contrasted open source
tools and Clos closed Source tools and
one of the key findings was that using
the guidelines of Dober
tests open source tools may more clearly
and comprehensively meet the guideline
requirements than would close Source
tools then the results are of course not
automatic just because the source is
open but there are some specific steps
that must be followed regarding the
design development and
validation so now we'll see one to one
mapping of the illustrative factors with
open source programming languages so now
we can ask these questions can the
program or algorithm be explained so
this explanation should be explained in
words not only in code this is very very
important statement that is
because people who are
working in law they may not understand
technology so they may not understand
the technical jargon of a programming
language okay so it has to be explained
in simple
terms then has the enough information
been provided such that thorough tests
can be developed to test the
program the third one is have error
rates been calculated and validated
independently the next one is has the
program been studied or peer
reviewed this is 100% possible because
whatever code you write is available on
jeub and anybody can review it and has
the program been generally accepted by
the
community yes so python is widely
adopted programming language now if you
consider these things we can speak with
respect to python but you can also speak
with respect to any open source
programming language such as
Julia so now let's see the problem that
is bank account or fundra
analysis so the most common and
continuing offense in recent times is
that of money laundering so to make it
easier for the police to trace the
illegal origin of money and undo the
complexities created in a series of Bank
transfers so Police Department was
looking for a solution that facilitates
efficient analysis of bank accounts to
identify the links among them so this
was a very very famous problem so this
problem was given by many law
enforcement
agencies in many
hackathons so we thought that this is a
very prominent problem to
solve so now let's see what are the
examples of money laundering so the
first example is that trade based
laundering so this technique involves
manipulating
invoices to disguise the M of money so
for instance person may might export
goods of $10,000 and produce the
inflated invoice of
$20,000
and then extra $10,000 money can be
claimed claimed as clean money then
there's something called structuring or
smurfing so this involves breaking down
large amounts of cash into smaller less
suspicious transactions
these transactions are usually spread
out over time and possibly across
different financial institutions to
avoid detection in our solution we are
going to focus more on structuring or
smurfing so we are going to detect such
cases the next one is offshore accounts
so money is deposited into offshore
accounts that offer greater secrecy and
are less
regulated the money might be moved
around several times making it difficult
to trace its Origins
then there's another way some people may
establish shell companies or fake
companies or trusts so criminals create
fake companies and Trust to disguise the
true origin of money so these companies
may just exist on paper but they don't
engage in any legitimate business
activities then there are some more like
gambling so individual might buy a
casino chips with illicit money and then
cash them out later for clean
money then intentionally they may lose
bets to another party who is on the
scheme then Bitcoin and cryptocurrency
so with the rise of digital currencies
criminals have turned to
cryptocurrencies as another way of
launder money due to its Anonymous
nature and one more important point to
note here is that nobody has control
over cryptocurrencies no government can
control so that's why you can see that
many times cyber criminals demand Ransom
in cryptocurrencies or
Bitcoins then overseas real estate so
invest uh black money into or dir money
into real
estate is under common tactic so the
property is bought with El money then
sold and then proceeds are considered
clean the next concept is politically
exposed persons it's also short for peps
so peps are individuals who have been
interested with prominent public
functions for example heads of state or
government senior politicians senior
government officials military officials
senior Executives of state owned
corporations and so on then there can be
International Organization peps so here
persons who are or have been interested
with a prominent function by an
international organization so refers to
members of Senior Management or
individuals who have been interested
with equivalent function such as
directors or Deputy directors or members
of the board of international
organization peps
then there's something called as family
members or you can also call them as RCS
relatives and Close
Associates so family members are
individuals who are related to pep that
is politically exposed persons either
directly or through marriage or similar
civil forms or partnership then Close
Associates So Close Associates are
individuals who are closely connected to
pep either socially or
professionally then there's something
something called as fatf that is the
financial action task force fatf was
established in 1989 and is based in
Paris so it leads a global action uh to
tackle moneya laundering terrorist and
proliferation financing so it researches
how money is laundered and how and
terrorism is funded promotes global
standards to mitigate the risk and
assesses whether countries are taking
effective action so in total more than
200 countries and jurisdictions have
committed to implement fatf's
standards and fatf's decision making
body that is called as the FF plenary
meets three times per year and holds
countries to account if they do not
comply with the standards so you can
refer to the link given in the slide for
more information and activities about
FF so this slide shows
how money laundering happens so this is
basically concentrating on structuring
or smurfing so there are three layers
one is placement second one is layering
and third one is integration okay in the
placement stage sender divides the large
money into small chunks and deposits
into multiple bank accounts then after
multiple bank
accounts there will be series of
transactions and it goes through
multiple bank accounts again sequence of
bank accounts
now on this slide you can see here that
there are some transactions which are
highlighted in red arrows some are in
green arrows so you can consider for
understanding purpose green arrows means
it's a legitimate transaction red arrows
means it's
a illegitimate or fraudulent uh
transaction okay so after laying
stage there's a integration stage so at
the end so money from these multiple
accounts will be deposited into
receivers account
so if you see the structure here it's
called structuring or smurfing and we
are concentrating on detecting such
fraud then the proposed solution so what
are we going to do here so first in the
first step we are going to collect the
bank statements from different
banks and we're going to create the DAT
data set of
accounts and there is a challenge here
the challenge is that each Bank
generates bank statements in their own
formats in some banks credit amount may
appear first in some banks debit amount
may appear first so the challenge here
is to consider all these multiple bank
accounts and bring them to uniform
format that is we have to Map Credit
amount to credit amount column we have
to map debit column to debit amount
column now we can apply here benfor law
so we'll see what is Ben fors law so
benfor law gives us some
indication some hints of possible money
laundering then after that we have to
import data of suspicious accounts and
here we also need to consider whether
these accounts are related to pep RCA or
even sanctions
data then generate a graph showing links
between accounts and transactions then
apply machine learning on the
graph then predict the possible money
laundering and generate the chain of
accounts with frent
because here investigation officers they
want to know the entire chain of
transactions now on the left side you
can see that I have mentioned record all
steps for evidence verification and
validation this is a very very important
step because this is not a normal
software this is a forensic software
okay so we have to record each and every
activity and prepare a report because in
court our opposition lawyer may ask how
you have arrived at the solution so in
that case we have to provide all this
evidence so one of the greatest features
of forensic evidence is that or forensic
softwares is that it has to be
reproducible let's see what's benfor law
so it's a phenomenological law and it's
also called as first digit law or also
called as leading digit phenomenon so
benfor law states that in listings in
tables or in statistics so digit one
tends to occur with probability of 30%
much greater than the expected
11.1% so there is no equal uh
probability so in this table you can
see it is clearly mentioned for each
digit what is the probability of
occurrence for digit one it is 30% for
two it is more than 70% for uh three it
is more than 12% for four it is more
than 9% and so on and this is the
formula P of D equal log the base 10 1 +
1 by D so where D is values of the
leading digits from 1 to 9 and whatever
graph you are seeing here right this is
the expected
graph
okay in forensic investigation process
we had discussed something about
validation okay so here how to make sure
that your data or information is not
modified so you have to make use of hash
functions so in Python you have a hash
Li module imported so use the different
algorithms present over here so we are
using sh 256 you also have sha 1 sha 2
md5 and so on and you can see here that
we have defined a message so the message
is broken
into uh two two messages so in first
message I have python e and in second
message I have a great programming
language and we are Computing message
Digest
okay and we see here that when the
message does
matches that means there is no
modification or alteration of the
evidence but in the second example you
can see here that for message X I have
added extra space so in this case it is
showing the output as false that means
there has been some
evidence of modifying or tampering of
the
evidence so so now let's see how to
apply benfor law here so first import
the necessary libraries pandas and naai
and also MPL because we want to
visualize the things and Define the
percentages so these the these
percentages are these values are
mentioned as per the benfor
distribution then read the bank
statements through CSV
then next plot the
graph and then compute the deviation so
we cannot have actual values here so
actual matching is not possible we have
to consider
some error margin some deviation range
we have to consider and if it is within
the deviation range then there is no
possible money laundry otherwise there
can be possible money
laundering so similarly in Python there
is a library called as benfor law you
can import benfor law package
directly so it's a very simple
Library so you can use pandas to read
the bank
statements then directly apply benfor
law over first
digit and there can be T Square method
that can be used
to perform statistical
tests
then you can apply the Ben Force law
algorithm
using fit function so compute the
significant P
value and if Ben Force value is greater
than G Square value then you can say
that anomaly is
detected and plot the values using plot
function okay so similarly you can
extend the code for second digit as well
as third
digit if if you are much interested yeah
so see here this is the graph you get
here although it closely resembles
vforce distribution but it is not
matching or it is not within the
deviation range okay for example first
case so it says
35.1% right so there's obviously
deviation okay so that's why we can say
that there
is anomal detected that means there
there can be possible case of uh money
laundering this is for second digit and
third
digit okay so next we have to visualize
the things so we have to show the
relationship between different bank
accounts if there is money laundering so
for that we can make use of Library
called as Network X okay so again read
the
transactions or bank statements then use
diagraph because we have to show the
arrows
from node one to node a that is from
bank account a to bank account B There
is a amount transfer that we have to
show with the graph so that's why we are
using diagraph method so there will be
always Source account and Target account
so arrow is from Source account to
Target account and depending on the
number of transactions and the amount of
transactions the weight of the
edge can be darker or
lighter so similarly draw the
graph and you can see this is the sample
output so we have we have assum assumed
hypothetical accounts and hypothetical
transactions between accounts so that's
why you can see here that between some
accounts the arrows are dark and in some
with some accounts the arrows are more
light so that means darker Arrow
indicates more number of transactions
more amount of transaction lighter Arrow
indicates less number of transactions
and less
amount
then logging module since it is a
forensic software we have to implement
logging module and we have to record all
the activities to record all the
activities logging module plays very
very important role and it is available
fortunately in Python so it's a buil-in
module used for flexible event logging
and there are some key components with
respect to Python's logging model so we
have logger we have log record Handler
and
formatter
so extending the previous program so you
can see here we have set up the logging
process by using login. basic config uh
function so Define the file name that's
called as app. log and it's open in
write mode because we want to write
everything to some file so we can call
it as log file here then what type of
message you want to add I want to add
informational message so I'm saying
loging doino if you want to note down
error message then you can say loging do
error so once you do this you're going
to record all the activities you're
going to prepare a report and you can
submit that report stating that this is
how we have got output or this is how we
have arrived at the
solution okay so finally the conclusion
so fontal analysis is very complex and
more Advanced Techniques and tools are
required so it's not so straightforward
as I have shown it in the uh
slides
okay thank you everyone for your time
and listening to my talk if there are
any questions I can take
them looks like we don't have any
questions for now but uh let's wait for
like one or two
minutes sure n thank
you uh gajendra I might have a question
uh do you have any resources from your
end for someone who's interested in
getting into forens six regarding uh
moneya laundering how can someone get
into this
field yeah um I had seen some online
courses uh which specifically deal with
money
laundering and you can explore something
called as forensic accounting so those
who are from
uh uh Finance
background okay so they can explore
something called as forensic
accounting okay we have one question in
the chat what kind of algorithm will you
apply on the
graph yeah so we have to represent the
graph
information uh uh into data set or
sequence of transactions and maybe we
can uh here we have to make use of
classification machine learning
algorithms another question for you is
what do you do after with all the
graphs yeah so graphs are basically
visualization techniques so it shows
what is the relationship between
different accounts so you might have
seen in one of our slides that some
arrows were darker some arrows were
lighter okay so we can we may ignore
some of
the uh lighter arrows but if you see
that the arrow is darker then that means
that there are more frequent
transactions more amount of transaction
is involved and that may be a possible
hint for the investigation officer that
okay there may be possible money
laundering okay but finally it's the
uh it it just assist the investigation
officers okay so it's the investigation
officers who has to investigate it and
identify whether it is uh true positive
or false
positive but it just gives some hints
some indication that there can be
possible money laundering